BRETT HESTERBERG: Welcome
to Google Cloud Next OnAir.
In this session, I'll cover
what's new with Cloud SQL.
My name is Brett Hesterberg.
And I'm a product
manager on Cloud SQL.
Even though we can't
meet in person today,
I'm hopeful that we can learn
a little bit about each other.
Using your question
pane and your comment
pane on your screen, if you
feel comfortable, please comment
in your job title.
Are you a database
administrator,
a reluctant database
maybe a DevOps engineer or
developer, or something else?
Also, please chat
in your preferred
or the relational database
that you work on most often.
Maybe it's MySQL, SQL Server,
Postgres, Oracle, Sybase, DV2,
or something else.
We'd love to know what
you're working on day to day.
Also, as part of Google
Cloud Next Expert Sessions,
I'm available to meet one on one
and talk more about Cloud SQL.
And I encourage
you to reach out.
Today we're going to talk
about four major areas.
One is how we can find more
flexibility in your database
environment, how we can protect
against the unexpected, gain
automatic transparency and
trusted security controls,
and lastly, we'll round out with
ways to easily stay up to date
without the risk.
Before we jump
into these topics,
let's start with a
quick look at Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is a managed
database service
that offers MySQL, SQL
Server, and PostgreSQL.
This means that if you
have an application that
uses MySQL, SQL
Server, or PostgreSQL,
it will work with Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL focuses on managing
mundane administration aspects
of these databases.
And I'll talk about
that a little bit more.
Beyond just application
compatibility,
it means that Cloud SQL is
compatible with your favorite
database administration tools.
So if you're a SQL
Server user, for example,
I encourage you to take a look
at the links on this slide.
Here, we're talking about
how SQL Server users can
use their favorite
administration tool, Cloud SQL,
incorporating the
Cloud SQL proxy, which
makes Cloud SQL instances in the
cloud look local to any machine
that you're working on.
Follow up on those
links if you're
interested in learning more.
When I think about
running a database,
this tends to be the technology
stack or the diagram of a stack
that I think of.
At the leftmost
column, we see things
related to running a data
center or a server environment
in general.
This means server maintenance,
racking and stacking, power,
HVAC, and networking--
things that
go into a data center or
any server environment.
Of course, this is taken
care of for you in the Cloud
where with Cloud SQL,
when we offer an instance
and you configure the number
of vCPU cores for RAM,
we make sure that you get
a consistent experience,
that number of cores in RAM,
even as our underlying hardware
changes.
Moving one column
to the right, we
look at the operating system--
both installation and
patching or keeping
the operating system up to date.
One more column to the right
is finally the database.
Here we're installing
the database.
We're keeping it up to date
with its own set of patches.
And we're starting to protect
data with scheduled backups.
And then rightmost
in the diagram
are things like high
availability, which usually
includes some health checking
and maybe automatic failover,
as well as scalability where
we're using often replication
to scale out reads to replicas.
We want to wrap this
whole technology stack
in monitoring so that
if there is a problem,
we're able to quickly
find the root cause.
Cloud SQL's job is take
this stack or this diagram
that you see, what it really
takes to run a database,
and wrap all of that
in an API, CLI, and UI
so that for your application
teams in your environment
or your developers, they can
easily start up and create
a dev or test database,
which might be very simple,
but just as easily create a
production-grade database,
which means it includes high
availability, which relies
on synchronous replication
and automatic failover,
includes a backup plan
for data protection,
and even cross-region
replication for disaster
recovery.
Again, all of these
wrapped in an API, CLI,
or UI that means in
just a few minutes,
you can get this set up.
Tim sums this up well.
And Tim Kelton is a
customer at Descartes Labs.
He says Cloud SQL gives
his team a bit more time
to work on the products that
provide value to his customers.
His team has decided
they're going
to spend less time on
certain aspects of database
administration and turn
those over to Cloud SQL
so they can focus
their time elsewhere
on products that are more
valuable to their customers.
I think Tim sums that up well.
And one thing to note here
is that the diagram I showed
and what's also backing Tim's
quote is a dedicated SRE
team, Sight Reliability
Engineering Team for Cloud
SQL that is on call 24 by 7.
These are the folks who
write the automation to make
sure our service is
healthy and runs well.
And when automation
fails, they're
also the folks who put
hands on a keyboard
to get a database
back up and running.
Now, that we've taken
a look at Cloud SQL,
we'll start to introduce
what's new, what have we been
up to in the past few months.
And I think what you'll find is
we have great momentum in terms
of enterprise features.
We're building on an
enterprise feature
set with a number of
these new features
that we'll cover today.
First, let's find
some flexibility
in your database environment.
We'll start with BigQuery
to Cloud SQL federation.
This enhancement gives analysts
a way to quickly reduce time
to value for business insight.
Perhaps, they want to explore
some data without setting up
a pipeline first,
or perhaps, they
have a quick question
they need to answer.
And that data might be spread
across multiple Cloud SQL
instances and even
other data sources.
With BigQuery-to-Cloud
SQL federation,
the analyst can query one
or more Cloud SQL instances
and join that data with
data that already resides
in BigQuery or
perhaps resides in one
of the other external data
sources supported by BigQuery.
What you see in this slide is
a depiction of a very simple
query an analyst is
running in BigQuery
where they're using
the external query
function, which is what
we use the ask Cloud
SQL to go run a query.
Here the queries
that are in Cloud SQL
has been input by
the analyst, which
means we're pushing
down the query
or asking Cloud SQL to run the
aggregates, for example, so
that we're not sending back
blindly a large table of data.
The data sent back from
Cloud SQL is in table format
and can then be joined
with other Cloud SQL data,
whether it be Q data or data
from another external source
supported by BigQuery.
All of this can be done
without setting up a pipeline.
And once an analyst is sure
that the insights being provided
are useful, from
there, the team can
decide to build pipelines for
a regular reporting schedule.
Next, we'll look at
committed use discounts.
And we don't often think
of pricing and flexibility
in the same sentence.
Hopefully, what you'll
find is that what
we've done with Cloud with
committed use discounts
is indeed flexible.
A committed use discount
is ideal for a workload
with predictable resource needs.
This is a way of saying that
they're great for environments
where you're running a number
of Cloud SQL instances 24 by 7.
We know that each month, you're
going to spend a certain amount
on Cloud SQL.
When you commit to a
one-year or three-year term
with a committed use discount,
or a CUD as I'll call them,
you receive either a 25%
or a 52% discount, one year
and three year.
The flexibility comes in
with committed use discounts
in that these are
easily and fully
transferable between
the database engines
supported by Cloud SQL, such
as MySQL, PostgreSQL, as well
as SQL Server.
The committed use
discounts or CUDs discount
against the vCPUs
or CPU cores and RAM
associated with each of
your Cloud SQL instances.
And here, if your
database's state changes,
let's say from SQL Server
to Postgres over time,
it's no problem.
Your CUDs will continue to
apply and you don't even
need to reach out to us.
Not only are these
fully transferable,
but you don't need to
take any specific action.
You purchase a
committed use discount
in a currency denomination,
for example, dollars.
And we charge your
instance rates
against that
commitment each month.
These are also fully
transferable between machine
sizes.
So you don't need to
forecast, which machine size
or how many CPUs
per machine you'll
be needing in the future.
You simply use CPUs
as you see fit.
They'll count against your
committed use discount.
In this way, your
database's state
can change quite dramatically
over, say, a three year period
of time without any
problems applying
to committed use discounts.
We hope this will make your
planning for committed use
discounts much easier with
a lot less forecasting
and that you find the whole
process to be indeed flexible.
Looking now at how to protect
against the unexpected,
we'll start with
disaster recovery.
In Google Cloud terms, we
often categorize disasters
as a region outage.
A region in Google
Cloud is comprised
of three or more zones, where
a zone is a separate failure
domain.
This means that if we
have a problem in Zone A,
it usually doesn't affect Zone B
or Zone C, so a guard in itself
against a regional outage.
But if a regional outage were
to occur where two or more
of the zones in the
region are down,
we have introduced a
cross-region replica
enhancement, or cross-region
replication enhancement that
allows you to guard against
this sort of outage,
a full-region outage.
With a cross-region
replica, you're
able to ensure that you
have a near-real-time copy
of your data in any
region around the world
other than in your
primary region.
We're using Google's
global network
as well as Google
Cloud's VPCs, which
are global in nature spanning
all regions in the world,
to ensure that this
experience is easy to setup.
And it can be made very secure
and private via our VPC option.
So what you see in this
slide, as in the screenshot,
that I'm selecting
a region, something
other than where I have
my primary instance.
So if my primary instance is
in, for example, US Central 1,
here I'm selecting US West 1
as my region for the replica.
And that's really
about all I have to do.
This will now take advantage
of my private VPC network.
So I know I'm securely
transferring data or copying
data, rather, in near-real
time to my replica.
And the replica is now
available in another region
than my primary instance.
This means in the
event that I have
a outage in my primary
region, US Central 1,
I know I have a
near-real-time dataset that
can be made available very
quickly in another region
in case of that disaster.
Of note here is that
this replica is also
a standard replica.
Meaning if you have users
in another region who
need low-latency
reads to a replica,
or you want to run reporting,
for example, in the replica,
you can certainly do so, knowing
that the replica is still
available for disaster
recovery purposes.
We talk a lot about disasters
and widespread outages.
You all have done a lot
of disaster planning
as part of your careers in IT.
What we tend to realize,
though, is often,
the more common event
is a user error.
We are sort of the
disaster, if you will.
I might drop a table or change
a row of data by mistake
and I want an Undo
button to get back
in time before I
changed that data,
so I get back to where I was.
We've long had point-in-time
recovery for our MySQL product
in Cloud SQL.
We're now proud to introduce
it for PostgreSQL as well.
With PostgreSQL, we store
transaction logs or WALs
for the past seven
days, which allow you
as a user to select a
millisecond at any point
in the last seven days.
So if I made a mistake on a
Friday afternoon, for example,
and I don't realize it
until Monday morning,
it's easy for me to get back to
the millisecond or the second
before I made that mistake on
Friday and recover that data.
It gives me an Undo button,
as I mentioned, and helps
to protect against the
more common issue, which
is user error.
These features add to Cloud
SQL's enterprise-ready list
for data protection
and disaster recovery.
And I think it's
worth summarizing
how to build a production
instance with Cloud SQL.
We start by enabling
automatic daily backups.
And I'd encourage
you to consider
taking more frequent on-demand
backups, especially when you're
making a major change
to your database.
For example, you might be
making a schema change.
It's a great time to
take an on-demand backup
just before you make that
change, in case anything
goes wrong.
I'd encourage you also to
enable point-in-time recovery,
so that you have
very granular restore
options for the last seven
days as the example was
with PostgreSQL.
You can get back now to
any millisecond in time
in case of a user error.
We also have an export
mechanism in Cloud SQL that
allows you to export your
data in a portable format
to Google Cloud Storage, or GCS.
This can be a multi-region
bucket, a single-region bucket,
or otherwise.
When you use
multi-region buckets,
it ensures that in
a regional outage,
your data is automatically
replicated and stored
in another region so you
can gain access to it.
You can also store these exports
in any other object storage,
meaning on premises or in
another cloud provider.
It allows you a very
portable format of your data,
so that you can take
it where you want.
In region, ensure that you
enable high availability.
High availability
tells Cloud SQL,
the high-availability
configuration,
tells Cloud SQL to
do automatic health
checking of your
instance and to set up
a synchronous
replication between zones
so that in the
event of a problem,
we automatically fail
over on your behalf,
bringing your database back
up even after a major fault.
This is necessary for the SLA
and generally good availability
guidance for any
production system.
Lastly, as I mentioned, to
protect against a region
outage, consider using our
cross-region replication
or cross-region replicas.
Again, you'll have a
near-real-time copy,
asynchronous
replication, which means
you'll have data available
to you in another region
should your primary
region have an outage.
And you can make
that data accessible
very quickly to applications
to get back online.
Looking now at how to get
automatic transparency
and trusted security
controls, we'll
start with Access Transparency.
Access Transparency gives
you near-real-time logs
when a Google
Cloud administrator
accesses your content.
Cloud audit logs already
provide visibility
into the actions of
your own administrators.
So for example,
your administrators
might be creating a
Cloud SQL instance,
taking a few
backups via our API.
All this is logged today.
However, this audit trail
typically or previously stopped
once your cloud provider support
or engineering team is engaged.
We previously didn't
log those transactions.
Now when you open a support
ticket with our support team,
with via Access
Transparency, you'll
see their actions
in your audit log
as well for our manual and
targeted accesses-- again,
either by support or engineering
to get your database back
online.
You can take this further
with Access Approval.
So beyond just logging
and viewing the access,
you can use the Access
Approval feature
to increase your
level of control
by requiring explicit
approvals before Google support
or engineering can access
your data or configurations
on Google Cloud.
I recommend taking a look
at both Access Transparency
and Access Approval to see how
they fit with your environment.
Next up, let's
look at encryption,
and specifically
customer-managed
encryption keys.
These keys are intended
for organizations
that have sensitive
or regulated data that
requires them to manage
their own encryption keys.
These keys are stored in
a key management system
that you manage.
We're using keys in
Cloud SQL that you manage
and we access them as
part of our operations.
Should you remove
access from that key,
then when Cloud SQL performs
a major operation next,
it won't be able to get the
key and access to that system
is shut down.
Again, this feature allows
you to use cryptographic keys
that you manage to control
your data at rest--
the data we store in Cloud SQL.
I mentioned earlier Google
Cloud's global VPCs.
We've introduced in
Cloud SQL support
for VPC Service Controls.
These generally in GCP allow
you to define very fine-grained
perimeter controls across
numerous Google Cloud Services,
of course, including Cloud SQL.
For Cloud SQL, this
pairs very well
with VPCs or private
IP addresses.
With the combination of private
IP addresses and VPC Service
Controls, you're now able to
make private your Cloud SQL
instances both from a data
path perspective as well
as a control path perspective.
The private IP or VPC allows
you to protect the data path--
the thing that your clients and
applications are connected to--
by using a private IP address
on a VPC that you control.
VPC service controls
for Cloud SQL
protect the
administrative API, who
can create Cloud
SQL instances, who
can take backups via the
API or the UI, for example.
You're now able to
make our administration
API totally private as well,
ensuring that you can control
where your teams can access
Cloud SQL instances, not
just on the data path,
but also on the control
path of the admin API.
Let's round out with how to stay
up to date without the risks.
As a reminder, Cloud SQL
has long offered maintenance
windows, which are
one-hour-per-week times when
you define that Google
can perform maintenance
on your instance.
In general, Cloud SQL
typically performs
maintenance once a
quarter on your instances
to apply patches and
keep things up to date.
We would adhere to
your maintenance window
as you see in this diagram.
One thing to note about
maintenance windows
is that we offer
certain timings.
If in a given project you
have dev and test database
instances, as well as your
production database instances,
you might put the dev
and test databases
on the earlier timing.
And you might put the production
databases on the later timing.
This ensures then that the dev
test instances on the earlier
timing get maintenance
or receive maintenance
about a week in advance of
your production instances.
That way, it gives you a
chance to test the updates
with the application before
they go into your production
environment.
We've recently added maintenance
notification and rescheduling.
When you opt in,
we'll email you a week
in advance of
maintenance, letting
you know that we're planning
to perform maintenance
in your next maintenance window.
You get a few options as
part of this notification,
including the
ability to reschedule
to a following window
one week later,
or the ability to apply
maintenance anytime
you click the Apply Now button.
You can also set a specific
time, any time in the next two
weeks, to apply
maintenance if you're not
happy with your current
maintenance window schedule.
This gives you much more
control as to when maintenance
is applied, especially on
your production instances,
and lets your teams know well
in advance that maintenance
will be performed.
To wrap up, hopefully
these features
help you find a bit more
flexibility in your environment
with things like BigQuery
federation and committed use
discounts; help you protect
against the unexpected,
be that user error with
point-in-time recovery,
or a regional outage with
cross-region replication
and disaster recovery.
They'll allow you to get
automatic transparency
and trusted security controls,
things like private IP
and now the addition of VPC
security controls, for example,
as well as customer-managed
encryption keys.
And we'll round it out with our
new maintenance notifications
and rescheduling functionality.
As you can see, Cloud
SQL is continuing
to build its momentum with
respect to enterprise features.
And you can expect to see more
of this in future offerings.
For next steps, I encourage
you to take a look
at two other sessions.
The first, a data
modernization story,
where McKesson talks about
their journey to Google Cloud.
And please, take a look at
the bare metal solution,
which will help you bring your
enterprise workloads to GCP.
If you want to see
Cloud SQL in action,
take a look at
our showcase demo,
which is a
[? whack-a-mole ?] style,
high-availability demonstration.
I mentioned high
availability briefly.
In this demonstration,
as I mentioned,
[? whack-a-mole ?] style,
you'll get to see how many Cloud
sequences can you make fail and
how many recover in the amount
of time you're
given in the game.
Take a look.
Lastly, get hands
on with Cloud SQL
and try it out with
our Qwiklabs Quest.
In the Quest, you'll be
introduced to Cloud SQL
from beginner knowledge all
the way through advanced,
touching on a lot
of the features
that I've talked about today.
By the end, I think you'll
feel very comfortable
using Cloud SQL.
And you'll hopefully
be taking advantage
of some of the enhancements that
we've brought out this year.
Thank you all for
spending this time with me
and watching the session.
As I mentioned, I'll be
available as part of our Google
Cloud Next Expert Sessions if
you want to meet one on one
and talk a little
more about Cloud SQL.
Thank you again.